hey it's Justine and I'm so excited
because right now I'm actually at
Spotify headquarters and they just had
an incredible stream on event where they
announced a bunch of new features in
Spotify and then I'm gonna go interview
Daniel Eck the co-founder and CEO of
Spotify I could not be more excited
oh my gosh Daniel thank you so much for
chatting with me today this is so
exciting of course well I'm happy to be
on I've been been watching your show for
a while so yeah happy to be here that's
so cool thank you and and I have been a
Spotify user for a very long time like I
don't even really remember how I got an
invite but I don't even know what the
year was but it was a long time before
Spotify was really readily available
yeah so I just remember making a lot of
people jealous yeah yeah and it's it's
funny because I I looked it up uh just
before Sue I think you got it through
Sean Parker back in the day uh as one of
their really really early people here in
the us who got it that's wild do you
remember what year it was that must be
uh probably 2010. wow so 13 years ago
that's a really long time yeah and I
think it's also been so fascinating just
kind of you know reading about Spotify
like the beginnings and kind of your
career it's so inspiring so do you want
to give people who may not be familiar
like how did Spotify actually come to be
yeah sure I'm born and raised in Sweden
and
um you know I had two big passions
growing up had music and technology and
I I was kind of one of these kids who
never could pick I was always like
playing an instrument and I was always
dealing with computers and technology in
in some shape or form and
um I got lucky enough to start a company
did pretty well ended up selling it and
as I was thinking about what to do next
um my co-founder and I we started
hanging out and we didn't know we were
going to start a company but he kind of
suggested to me look I mean what are
your passions and I said well my
passion's always been music and
technology and he's like well so why
don't we do something in music and
Technology I said well I don't think
that's a great idea this is like a
terrible thing because it's only piracy
going on all over the world and you
can't get that work and he said well
okay but what if you solve that how
would you do that and I said well I
don't think that's possible I think
here's all the problems but I guess you
could potentially do this and I said
okay well but all these problems how
would you solve that and then the Y came
and the Y came and and and uh the more
and more answers I started giving I was
like well maybe there is a chance here
to do something and back then it was it
was pretty simple it was based on this
idea that the music industry was in a
free fall yet you had something
consumers loved which is all the world's
music available through these pirate
sites and I realized you couldn't sue
the consumers uh which was what the
music industry was trying at the time
but you had to build a better experience
than piracy and that's where it started
and I realized it had to be legal and I
realized it had to compensate artists
fairly for that process and that's when
we started working on Spotify and it
took uh like three years to to get all
the licenses done uh I probably thought
it would take two months but you know
that's what happens with these
entrepreneur Journeys it goes up and
down up and down and then we launched
and then it took an other like three or
four years before we were able to launch
here in the US yeah I just love that
journey and I just feel like it's so
cool to hear and I think it's inspiring
for a lot of other entrepreneurs and
even creators and where Spotify is Now
is really it's pretty impressive like
what you guys have done in the music
industry making so many jobs for actual
creators being able to do their passion
and what I love so much about the stream
on presentation is you focused a lot on
creators and I think it's also
interesting because we all say the word
creators and that encompasses so many
things musicians artists podcasters and
even audiobooks what are some of the
things that you guys launched today or
whenever you guys are watching this are
listening yeah what can creators expect
so what we launched today is an all-new
Spotify experience where uh it really
starts with the home feed so it's an
entirely new home feed that's very
visual very interactive that allows you
as a consumer to be able to now engage
and see the creators the way they want
to be seen as a creator that means you
have the opportunity to use video as a
way of expressing yourself it means that
you have the way of using transcripts as
a podcaster and we're going to be able
to pick out interesting places just for
you using our machine learning
technology that you might be interested
in so even if I've never listened to you
before but for instance I know stuff
about Spotify and I'm generally
interested you'd get right into
precisely this moment in our
conversation so that person gets a
chance to listen to that and ends up
engaging and thereby also discovering
hopefully you and start listening to
more and more of your great content and
that's the start and then it really
comes through an entirely new updated
experience where everything from our
search and Discovery also changes with
more ways for you to discover great
content more great new tools for you as
a content creator as well to reach those
fans no it's awesome and my sister's so
sad she couldn't be here because we host
a podcast together and we started during
the pandemic and we found anchor and it
was honestly life-changing everything
was so simple amazing and I was like
okay we have to make sure we're shooting
video because when Spotify launches
video we need to be ready
from the beginning that was our entire
plan was like when you guys launched
like we're here we're ready so that is
something that I'm super excited that
you guys are really leaning into so for
people who may be interested in starting
a podcast or who have audio podcasts
what kind of features are you guys you
know helping out with for video again as
you mentioned video took sort of the
front stage Center uh today for us at
Spotify and for us it's it's
um it's it's an important way to express
yourself both as a Creator but I think
uh we're you know on our side also
creating lots of more ways for people
just generally to engage with these
creators so you uh would see us do q a
we saw us do polls as well so there's
going to be a lot more ways for for
people just to engage with creators and
for creators to engage with their
audience as well we also have updated an
entirely new podcaster for DOT
spotify.com which is our tool that
allows now anchor creators to get the
benefit of all the other great Spotify
tools that you get access to and of
course as you mentioned rolled out video
now for all creators no matter what
hosting platform you're using as well
it's really cool I know I'm very excited
about it something else I thought was
really cool is the countdown to albums
for artists it's a big deal you know
many times like a podcast say you know
you may work on an episode but you may
have a pretty
pretty regular frequency of maybe
releasing content weekly or bi-weekly
but an artist when they're working on an
album sometimes that process might take
a year or even two years so it's very
important for them to be able to ask
they're dropping a single for instance
build that kind of an excitement and
anticipation for the album as well
having that product we've seen you know
gets more than 80 percent to listen to
the album then uh the first week who
pre-saves the album not such a great
idea and super helpful for artists
another thing is AI is pretty much the
top of everyone's mind today and I think
a lot of people don't even realize a lot
of the stuff that you guys are doing has
been AI all of the recommendations of
course you do have people in-house doing
that you also launch the the AI DJ which
is so just it's so fun yeah and so how
do you see kind of going forward how AI
is going to help listeners and also help
creators we think about it from two ways
so I think when when people hear the
word they either get very worried or
they get very excited and it seems to be
either one of those extremes and at
Spotify we've we've always thought
really really hard about what position
we take of AI everything from if you
think about our wrapped on how we do
storytelling with data we knew privacy
and uh individual expression is
importance we put the ability for you to
share if you like it front and center
instead of the platform just sharing it
automatically to everyone that's just
one example but then even in terms of
recommendation we don't try to maximize
the time spent in app as an example we
try to maximize the influence that we
have by shortening the distance between
between the person wanting to watch
something listen to something and the
person then actually hearing it and
those are just a few ways that may seem
kind of trivial but underneath the
surface actually makes all the
difference in how the algorithms
actually work and as a creator for
example what we're actually trying to do
is build meaningful connections we're
not just trying to get you to create a
viral clip on Spotify but we're actually
trying to get you to create whether
whether this person actually came back
and listened to more episodes is more
meaningful for our signal than it is
that they particularly enjoy that that
clip that you posted as well so it just
fundamentally works very different
underneath the surface than other
platforms and for us I think that means
if you're a creator that means you can
really trust so you can build an
audience on Spotify and you can be able
to sustain that audience and we don't
shy away from from that responsibility
including of course helping creators
with monetization as well yeah I also
saw how you guys were doing merch and
ticket sales and that kind of things
obviously I'm not a musician so I guess
four musicians traditional ones like
what are you guys doing to implement
more of like the merchandise and extra
monetization streams yeah I I think
you're touching on something that's very
important so the way we're looking at
the world is there are obviously lots of
types of creators that we were talking
about but perhaps the most important
definition for us is whether you're
doing it to share content with your
friends or whether you're actually
trying to do this as a business so
Spotify we want to be the best home for
you that aspire to be professional or
are are already a professional Creator
and that means we have to do things a
little bit differently than a platform
where for instance you're focused mostly
around communication with friends and
family but one of those realization is
that many creators don't rely on just
one Revenue stream it can't just be
around advertising it can just be about
sort of paying customers but oftentimes
it's both of those things and perhaps
even more and on the music side that's
been very true for a long time so if you
think about an average musician an
average musician has their music of
course that they record and put out but
they're also touring they also have
merchandise and so as we look at this
thing what we realize there's many of
the things that we built for the
musicians are also the things that we
believe almost all creators would want
at some point in time you may have
digital merchandise you may have
physical merchandise but you may also
put on your own events as well and we
want Spotify to be the best home for you
as a Creator to be able to do all of
those things yeah you're talking about
Digi
it's a controversial thing with like
nfts but like what do you think of like
the web 3 landscape I mean obviously
that's probably future thinking but I
mean I think it's very fascinating and
the tech is really interesting and I
think you can do a lot there as well I
agree with you I'm not sure we found the
right product just now that sort of both
captures the imagination is long-term
sustainable both for creators and
consumers but I I look at it and the
most important thing is we want to allow
for as much experimentation as possible
to happen quite often what ends up
happening is some amazing crater out
there figures out something that none of
us would have imagined and it's really
through that that other people then
start learning you know I I've been for
instance checking out Mr Beast and some
of the stuff he's been doing and and
it's it's pretty fantastic to just see
how many other lines of businesses he's
building up now on the side too and I
think even if all creators won't be at
that scale I still think the idea is the
same which is you you're building your
audience you're building this unique
relationship to that audience audience
and and that trust can extend to other
things as well and that's a very big
part of the focus we have at Spotify I
think it's also cool you're doing the
patreon integration and so do you want
to talk about how that works because I
know a lot of my friends and a lot of
creators also use patreon yeah sure
absolutely so I think another thing
that's very unique and different about
Spotify is we are an open platform we
believe that the most important thing is
to give as much Choice as possible both
to Consumers and creators alike and so
some others may have believed oh well
patreon must be we must build all these
functionality ourselves we can't work
with anyone else but Spotify really from
day one has always been built on
Partnerships and for me as a consumer an
asset Creator as well I think it's just
great because Essie rightly pointed out
there's lots of creators who are using
patreon but there's also a lot of people
who are consuming content on Spotify so
one of the problems at the moment moment
is if I want to consume any of that
patreon content I may have to do it in a
place that's not my actual audio
listening place or where I would watch
videos so there's two separate
experiences almost when this comes live
the way it's going to work is that you
as a Creator is going to be able to link
to your patreon thing and the consumer
can then authenticate against that and
unlock all the content that you want to
make available for your uh for for your
patreon subscribers as well and that's
just an amazing way again talking about
sort of not relying on one Revenue model
but allowing you as a Creator to have a
lot of control over what you want to do
with your business and us just building
sort of the tools and and the platform
that enables that that seems to be a
common Spotify Trend you guys identify a
problem and you figure out how to solve
it and I think that's pretty impressive
thanks yeah I mean we certainly try but
I won't say we always get it right I
mean the the the big thing I think that
I've learned as an entrepreneur is just
understanding how
um
how important culture is and I used to
think that was like a buzzword that that
wasn't that important but ours is a
culture of experimentation we actually
get a lot of things wrong but hopefully
we will evolve and we will learn from
them and we will try more things as well
and it's always about sort of taking
those insights trying to do some
something
um learning from it as we get feedback
and yeah move on faster and better yeah
I mean it's a testament even that you've
been there for so long you started this
company and really carrying it through
and I just loved so much watching the
presentation and seeing how much you
guys care about creators and really
making sure that they're at the
Forefront so was there anything else
today that you presented that you know
people may have missed or might need to
know well I I guess the one thing uh to
touch on
um is perhaps AI DJ uh oh yeah oh my
gosh yes I completely forgot it's so
cool yeah so how does this all work I
mean it's it's it's so much fun
um and and it's it's I probably
shouldn't and say it say it because it's
kind of picking among my favorite
children but but it is my favorite
feature at Spotify at the moment we've
constantly been playing around with
recommendations and giving you more
choice and
um as Gustav hustar had a product set on
stage today our goal is to try to save
you time and one of the moments that we
know people listen to a lot is in the
car when you're driving but you still
want to have a great mix but you're not
entirely sure what to do and you want to
understand why you're getting served the
recommendations you are so we created AI
DJ to do exactly just that and it's
powered by X who is an actual Spotify
employee I met him today yeah which was
awesome yeah he's a super cool guy and
it's funny because he uh gives you all
this amazing context around music and it
it's scary good and his voice is scary
good and so quite often
um internally we really thought he had
recorded all these things I'm on it
coming up now I got some hip hop your
kind of hip-hop
uh and it was only when he started
speaking Swedish which he definitely
doesn't know how to do that uh we were
like oh this is getting scary good
that's hilarious so it's basically you
took his voice track and was able to
implement that even into other languages
as well yeah we've taken his voice uh
had it recorded all the intonations
um you know phrasings all of these
different things we've trained that on
our models we acquired a company a while
ago called sonalytics that helps us do
exactly that they also by the way uh
created Val Kilmer's voice and Top Gun
so it's a really cool company that now
is part of Spotify their first product
now is AI DJ where where X now is
talking about music and he's sharing a
lot of context in history
um about each track too and these are
not things we told it these are things
that uh through our partnership with
openai that it's now able to tell the
world about for instance a background
story worry about a track
and of course why you're hearing that
track so what kind of things would it
say of like why I was listening to it
would be like a date that I or was it
yeah playlist so it might be like
um now we're gonna go back and listen to
um your favorite music during the summer
of 2017. do you remember this one and
then it would start playing but it might
also give you more specific around the
track itself where did you know that
this song was recorded by
um or produced by this person who you
also liked these other tracks by
um so just more personal context it's
like having your own DJ in your pocket
uh that could be with you when when
you're driving or commuting or out
running or whatever you might be doing
uh and it's yeah it's my favorite at the
moment and like this is why AI is cool
and I think people think like AI robots
like running around town no this is what
it's all about yeah I I totally agree
um and that's kind of why I said I think
like people are like polarized on AI
it's like either it's really great or
it's really bad
and obviously yes a technologist I I see
mostly the positive stuff I I think what
we did here is struck a tone where we're
making it come alive and it feels
personal and feels like it's an actual
real human being who's talking to you
giving you context and know you really
well and know your music tastes super
well and can give you all that great
music for when you're cooking or running
or whatever you're doing I'm so excited
about it I guess one last thing you were
talking about sort of like this Spotify
culture and I guess for any other
entrepreneurs or business people or
creatives who are running a business
what do you think is the most important
thing to kind of cultivate that culture
that you guys have made I actually don't
think it's that important that you have
our culture I think the most important
thing is that you try to Define what
your culture is yeah that's what I meant
like how how do you I guess instill
whatever your culture is like you
personally as a leader like what is what
advice can you give to someone well my
advice uh I guess the first thing
um I modeled myself on probably all the
other famous entrepreneurs
um that you'd have the jobs the gates
and so on and so forth but what I
realized the realized after a while is I
wasn't any one of them I was just me and
when you're not authentic it's really
hard to get across and this is what I
would say to any Creator too it's like
don't try to be anyone else you just got
to be you and
um so it took me a few years to find
that and that was probably like the most
important part of the spot modified
Journey when I started being authentic
to me and I started
asking the company to you know have
values that were aligned with me too and
that's a highly personal thing as well
and so when I'm watching Spotify today
it's been 17 years it's it's kind of
crazy because it feels like I've got
like this teenager uh who's who's kind
of unruly it's not always doing what I
wanted to do but you can definitely see
yourself in like bits and pieces of what
it's doing yeah it's it it's pretty
crazy that way but I would just say be
you be really authentic and then be
consistent just you have to reward the
positive things you want to see in in
the culture and you have to try to very
very fast and clearly when you see
something that's not marking up to that
culture you want to build go in and fix
that well thank you so much for chatting
with us today and we'll see you guys on
on the DJ yeah thank you thank you so
much
thank you
[Music]